[Applause]
what up my name is Tom Thumb and I gotta
say it's a pleasure to be back at TEDx
when I first stepped upon the Sydney
stage in 2013 as a starry-eyed boy from
Brisbane I had no idea that I was about
to deliver the most-watched TEDx
presentation ever but you know I was
stoked because it was completely
unexpected
however standing before you today as a
slightly inflated time battered version
of myself five years later I'm very
confident confident that I'm about to
deliver the most instantly switched off
and walked out on vomit inducing talk of
all time I'm about to show you things
that I think you'll find hard to unsee
but all in the name of science first for
those unfamiliar with what I do I guess
if you distilled it right down to its
essence you would call me a beatboxer
[Music]
[Music]
okay
and being a beatboxer it means that
professionally I am 100% reliant on the
flexibility of the unfiltered human
voice and for years my contemporaries
and I have been fielding questions like
oh my god that's so cruel when did you
figure out you could do that after I
practice for thousands and thousands of
hours and what do you do for a real job
you're full-time beatboxer your honor
but there is one question that I get
quite a lot that's a little bit more
difficult to answer and that is how are
you doing it how are you making those
noises and I mean I know muscle memory
dictates where I position my lips in
order to be but I have no idea about the
inner mechanics of everything you know
all the flappy bits and kind of dangly
things and how they interact in in a way
that allows me to support it
metaphorically I know how to drive I
just don't know what's under the hood so
I decided to find out and invite five
thousand captive strangers a few
uncomfortable cameras everybody watching
online in their browser history into a
place where not even the most intimate
of encounters have been my throat and to
help me do that I'd like to introduce to
the stage a very specialist guest from
the Queensland voice Centre a man that's
been in my mouth more times than I care
to admit a legend of the larynx ENT
doctor and laryngeal
Mackey brought her Thank You Tommy thank
you and very good evening everyone it is
a pleasure to be here on the TEDx stage
tonight she's not warming up his hands
doesn't get that intimate we set out a
little while ago to try to go deep into
the world and the throat of this
beatboxer extraordinaire to try to
understand how such a vast array of
sounds are humanly possible and what we
found these are going in the mouth by
the way and what we found was something
absolutely amazing even after my two
years of laryngeal surgery in Harvard
Medical School with world-renowned
professor Stevens I tells we never saw
anything as extraordinary or fascinating
as this that's what we're going to show
you tonight
all right so for those of you who might
be a little squeamish the next 10
minutes or so we'll get incrementally
more graphic and stomach-churning so
let's get everybody to use the bucket so
when we make sound we take use the vocal
cords to take air from the lungs and
then turn it into a vibrating air column
in the throat if you think of it like a
trumpet we've got the mouthpiece that's
the vocal folds and then the horn
section is the throat if we took your
head off took a bit of your neck off and
left you as a torso with just your vocal
folds vibrating this is what you'd sound
like
[Music]
pretty hard to communicate but
fortunately we've got a throat we've got
all the soft tissues and that actually
gives you all the incredible dynamics of
sound that you'll hear tonight now this
is a rigid laryngoscope spicy boy ten
millimeters in diameter gives us the
highest resolution image of the larynx
we can get and we tee it up with a
stroboscope here and a trigger
microphone the mic will pick up the
frequency and that'll allow us to show
you how this all works so if we can have
the lights down turn the light on here
[Music]
so I've got the frequency of sound
matched with the stroboscope that's the
light you're seeing flickering in the
cup and that's at about 80 Hertz or so
so what we can do then is we can take
that and put the phase of the strobe and
the sound just out of sync that lets us
capture real-time
slow-motion activity of vibrating
tissues when we apply that to the larynx
we get this fluid slow motion of the
vibrating vocal folds so that's what
we're gonna get on and do all right you
ready yeah okay so here we go we're
gonna have a look at the voice box that
yeah it's very hard not to gag with this
say E so down the bottom you see the
vocal cords the little cord like
structures
[Music]
and now just look at the skin on the
neck and you'll see how strong the light
is to penetrate the skin all right so if
you have the lights back on all right so
just give us a comfortable E
so that's the vibrating vocal folds
about 120 Hertz means they've collided
at a hundred and twenty times a second
just to make that sound and we can also
see that they're absolutely perfectly
normal so all is beatboxing all those
sounds for years with Tom's way of doing
it absolutely no damage whatsoever
that's that's really remarkable well
done so watch now as the vocal cords go
from high pitch to low pitch you'll see
them go from long and skinny to short
and fat and what you can see is that his
vocal range is so extreme much more
extreme than any other performer I've
worked with the Machine actually can't
capture the really high pitches so we
know that whistle register is somewhere
around 2092 Hertz
that means the vocal cords well over
2,000 times a second of banging together
just to make that sound that's really
extraordinary if you think about them
they're only 15 millimeters long that's
barely the width of your thumb that's in
Creek that's amazing this organ can do
such a thing
so now we're going to swap over to the
flexible laryngoscope this is a little
more graphic your bottom is EXFO
that wasn't in the scripts
[Applause]
secondhand yeah now we've had to time
this bit perfectly because the
requirement for local anesthetic got a
numb the nose get the camera in it
doesn't help for producing a lot of the
sounds but it gives us a really cool
view of what's happening so hold on to
the stomachs and let's see what we can
do so we're going to the back of the
nose and there you can see the soft
palate a lot of the sounds we make from
day to day even the simple ones are
incredibly complex the sound Cup for
example it's the soft palate sealing up
precisely against the back of the nose
so if you say it loudly five times feel
your own soft palate snapping against
the back of the throat alright so this
is what it looks like when Tom does it
cut cut a cacophony of cackling
kookaburras and cockatoos and kakadu
couldn't quite quit tenorman alright now
in the beatboxing world of course they
can use that for all sorts of different
effects I can help yeah yeah this is
fine when professionals
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right now we're going to slide down
a little further if you just have the
have the lights off and just see if you
can see the light in the mouth somewhere
you'll be able to see exactly where the
camera is at all right so so what you
can see there that's the base of the
tongue the sidewalls of the screen
that's the pharynx all muscle walls and
in the deep dark decks is the larynx
should we have the lights back on yeah
let's turning a bit creepy with them off
turn the lights on Thanks
good now having examined over about
15,000 larynxes and throats in my time I
can tell you that Tom's is as
anatomically normal as anyone elses it's
just his unique use of all the muscles
and soft tissues which lets him do all
these amazing sounds that you're going
to hear so we will dissect some of these
sounds for you now mmm okay
so what he's doing is he's changing the
shape and the length of the vibrating
air column using rhythmic contractions
of all the muscles to generate all those
sounds that you're hearing
[Music]
and now there's rhythmic movements of
the they're written I'd Carthage's way
down there rocking back and forth to
create that different sound
we like to call this speak debase and
what do you see is that collapsing all
the tissue down allows a different kind
of really deep bass note alright so some
with local anesthetic on board a big
black hose in the nose we're going to
let loose a sliver of his repertoire and
seal this in play yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]